der melancholische aspekt dabei die
inzwischen ist die gegend wegen der
1945 kapitulieren die japaner und ziehen
dieses gebäude ist nicht einfach
aus dem 99 jagdgeschwader wurden details
ausbeutung erstreckt sich auf alle
festung spiegelt die stürmische zeit
österreicher bitten das deutsche militär
board sie setzten gas ein und zwar
einem bergkamm oberhalb der hauptanlage
einheit gehen die tasci german hervor
geheimnis dieses ortes scheint am fuße
die art der ausbildung des bahnbrechend
in der ländlichen gegend erhebt sich
kriegsministerium genehmigte die
silo in seenot ist in einem riesigen
batterie kann o2
kaiserreich ist eine aufstrebende
pläne der anlage neues leben
schwindende guttenberg auch bekannt als
jahrhundert war eine seltsame epoche und
unterhalten die seele in enge gänge und
ganze reihe von mauern über den berghang
schreien überragt die landschaft noch
weltkriegs kommt die erste große
150 jahren ihres bestehens übersteht die
verbirgt sich etwas beunruhigendes eine
der bauten vergessen und verlassen
kommt aus dem tunnel und sieht einen
mai 1915 nur sechs tage nach den
während des zweiten weltkriegs geleistet
weitreichenden einfluss auf das
des zweiten weltkriegs dort die
bauten weisen auf eine bewegte
italiener wurden überrascht und ihre
berghang der lange heiß umkämpft war man
gold erz abgebaut haben gelangt es über
korea dann nehmen die japaner den norden
weitere orte wie diesen und an allen war
force base anfangs hielt genannt hier
atomsprengkopf ist die titan rakete die
nicht der einzige der die alten gemäuer
der jahrhunderte viel mitgemacht aber
gigantisches gelände mit recht gut
treten die venen aus der festung aus auf
erfüllte die anlage und warum arbeiteten
einem regelrechten juwel von einem
champion county illinois steht eine
mit einer letzten schlacht aber erst
geschult werden müssen für alle
nicht nur die vergangenheit eines luxus
allein großgezogen das japanische
lebensbereiche
durchs becken und über diese beiden
den festungsmauern verbirgt sich
air core wuchs von vielleicht 20 tausend
wieder in der sie entsteht das ergebnis
wieder aufgebaut und in ein museum
artillerie stände verbunden durch einen
anfang schon bald wird die anlage zu
schönen landschaft als wandergebiet
betrieben sich durch den fels zu
verfallen es wurde massiv beschädigt
diese riesige burg sie wird fast wie ein
äußerst giftiges gas fonds gehen
kolonialmacht nach einer zeit der
die umstrittenen gebiete zu
um unterstützung das mit einer
kontrolle übernahmen kümmerten sie sich
pazifik krieg in vollen gange
sie eine art riesigen schornstein eine
österreich ungarn und italien entstanden
hangar untergebracht damit das personal
steinernen bauch die vegetation rand an
vergangener zeit einst mühsam erschaffen
kriegsgeschehen
der treppe zu legen dort hofft man zu
traurige wahrheit solcher orte ist dass
inmitten eines asiatischen
müssen sich hinter jedem dieser fenster
riesig ganz besonders wenn sie leer
auf den zweiten blick erkennt man dass
einzuhauchen die burg pitten sie soll
heute das relikt eines grausamen
herausforderung auf dem flugplatz zu
auch die auswahl der auszubildenden ist
winzige krankenstationen und veränderten
geschichte hin jemand hat den aufwand
als mechaniker ausgebildet aber einige
wo könnte man seine geheimnisse besser
und fein vielleicht ein überbleibsel aus
die überreste der 13 ebenen
erhaltenen gebäuden es wirkt ein
wird trägt entscheidend zu den kriegs
königlicher luxus helle große räume
in europa steht plötzlich auch die
denkbaren bedrohungslagen gewappnet sein
heimsucht
ein altes kloster halten es fällt sofort
gegeben und man verlegte sie von hier
jahrhunderte erdulden musste stehen die
manche ruinen erinnern an dunkle zeiten
umgewandelt werden
jeden tag mächtig was los ständig waren
linien brachen schnell ein innerhalb von
nachdem eine halbe million männer
die enorme summe von über 600 millionen
was es letztlich am härtesten traf war
bekannt es gibt sogar einen pfad des
palastes denn hier haben sich doch ganz
burg einer schlacht nach der anderen
chinas ins visier und besetzen 1931 die
nicht um die bewegte vergangenheit der
berge
mächtigste waffe der usa der raketen
reihe verlassener lagerhäuser und sie
kolonialreichs lag
einem wichtigen rädchen im getriebe der
kriegseintritt italiens erteilt luigi
totalitären sowjetunion mit einem haufen
japans streben nach macht hat zum
es schützengräben sind dies ist die
knapp 200 meter langen graben
transportsystem für den bergbau durch
grausame geschichte deren echo die
ein geist im vorhang verderben
zerklüfteten küste von django rasch in
verstecken als im keller
hier hunderte amerikaner
ersten schwarzen geschwaders auf dem
englisches herrenhaus aus einem tim
schloss das ist nicht ganz klar
unter der herrschaft der japaner wurden
denn später bringt eine andere nutzung
gebäude es wird im vergleich sehr edel
steht
ganze wände wurden eingerissen
gegend im westen der ukraine steht ein
ist ein einzigartiges misch design aus
1915 tritt das land unter den
umstrittenen waffe zu hilfe kommt der
sie in kriegszeiten zwar enorm wichtig
soll die gesamte innengestaltung
wir hoffen dass sie viele besucher
92 festungen man wird diesen ort war man
bisschen wie eine eigenständige stadt
nach alabama diese piloten wurden
gefallen waren
finden die technische ausbildung und das
bemühungen der usa bei
den wänden empor die natur erobert ihn
einer luxuriösen zeit in dieser gegend
burg sie machten daraus ein sanatorium
von ihnen hatten von flug erfahrung und
kolonialreichs das nicht lange währen
heute nur noch schatten ihrer selbst
gigantischen rohrleitungen bauen lassen
rassenpolitik in den usa selbst auf den
leute unterwegs von a nach b nicht nur
die schmelze
damit zielten sie auf die italienischen
zeugen von wohlstand darin hielt man
mauern noch immer
aber die kriegszeiten dauert nicht ewig
friedens der die stellungen und das
slowenischen bergen thront eine reihe
zwei wochen fing die gesamte front an zu
dollar bewilligt um eine luftfahrt
der angriff auf pearl harbor war ein
eine bizarre und unerwartete wendung in
andere dinge abgespielt
auf wie ruhig und friedlich es dort ist
us kriegsmaschinerie
wirtschaftlichem wachstum und expansion
andere waren einst leuchtende beispiele
wir haben soldaten verschiedenste
taiwan inmitten einer berglandschaft
atomwaffen gegenüber
burton film
controller seinen truppen den
hier wurden jahrzehntelang kupfer und
offenen konflikt mit den usa und
janet hat maßgeblich zum erfolg der
als der zweite weltkrieg endet gibt es
der zweite besitzer burg ist was wusste
sind nicht allein das ist ein
mittlerweile leeren räume um dunklen
oder ist dieser überwucherte bau der den
aus dem tal transportierte über den
wirken sie irgendwie gespenstisch als
für tuberkulose patienten sie
sind aber in friedenszeiten eigentlich
man richtete stellungen ein um den
ausgebildet werden kann
anziehen und zu altem glanz zurückkehren
zu beginn des zweiten weltkriegs
dann steht man einfach nur vor einer
berüchtigten general luigi cardona in
wir zu bürgern zweiter klasse
opulenter pracht im inneren und
gebäude mit ungewöhnlichem charme mitten
grabensystem verbindet heute sind viele
pilotentraining für die kampfflugzeuge
machten sich außerordentlich gut in den
fünf das dach wurde erneuert
mandschurei
oder der einfluss einer anderen kultur
heute steht die anlage größtenteils leer
zurück
anfangs entscheidung ausgebildet das war
der burg weitere todesfälle mit sich
ihn wurde das erz abtransportiert
die sich von der anlage aus erstrecken
sollte
bälle und motto abend ab mit theater
von ruinen am rand einer steilen
manche finden das gebäude sicher
stellung und dort unten in gut einem
zeit ihre geheimnisse zu lüften an der
angriffsbefehl
1917 nähern sich cordon us-truppen dem
italienischen stellungen lagen auf der
in den jahren 1943 44 an so ein anstieg
die einst prachtvoll angelegte burgtor
uns in den tal unterhalb dieses ortes
prüfstand
japan führte sich auf wie großbritannien
noch immer bemühen sich die taiwanesen
bröckeln
ausbildungen durchlaufen
infrastruktur in den usa zu entwickeln
wendepunkt für die usa kurz darauf trat
distinguished flying crosses
wird trotz allem was dieser ort über die
die ärzte wurden oben angeliefert und
an
großbritannien geführt dadurch kommen
von hier aus die italiener von westen
sei da gerade etwas riesiges
aber spuren am berghang deuten darauf
wasserlache und kommt nicht mehr weiter
gänge bis heute erfüllt
statt mit dem beginn des zweiten
und eine riesige anlage die zu einem
kursen
seiner geschichte
eine feuerwache lagerhäuser wohngebäude
gold verarbeitet der tunnel war ein
die vereinigten staaten erkannten zu
sie waren darauf vorbereitet im
1895 hat das teil war von den chinesen
für technologischen fortschritt und
westlichen mächte im kalten krieg
nicht gebraucht werden sie leisten einen
angriff der italiener zu stoppen die
herrschte in der us gesellschaft noch
militärischer effizienz im außenbereich
endlich wieder hoffnung auf frieden aber
das leben wurde viel härter es gab sogar
ein wichtiger meilenstein in der
amerikanisches jagdgeschwader das
poesie und musik zwischen diesen bänden
vielleicht hat die burg genug
den krieg ein wo ein beobachter hat ihn
ab den 1700 70er jahren herrschte nach
kilometer entfernung
während des kalten krieges im
eines anderen herrschers welchen zweck
gruselig und beunruhigend
ausgezeichnet das ist wirklich
das ist ein splitter von einer
also beschloss man am stützpunkt wo sie
verschwunden beinahe auf unerklärliche
alles war voller maschinen und überall
anderen seite ein stück weit entfernt
um ihnen rankt sich eine düstere legende
wenn man sich diesen palast ansieht ist
schlucht aus der ferne könnte man es für
aber das innere eines hangars legt nahe
nach dem abzug der japaner haben die
kommen sehen konnte
zu hochzeiten des empire die japaner
geschichte des stützpunkts
beigetragen amerika ist heute auch
üppige grün dort scheint eine festung am
um die unabhängigkeit des inselstaates
völlige rassentrennung
bobic becken und der berggemeinde
neue arbeiter auf die insel
dies ist tunnel 6
und die ausmaße sind gewaltig es wirkt
ernstfall tatsächlich den abschussbefehl
sie kehrt wieder zu ihrem ursprünglichen
hoffnung stille zeugen vom
das war nicht gerade der typische palast
kamen eine halbe million menschen zu
diesem zeitpunkt dass das 99
durchhaltevermögen um noch für lange
amerika in den krieg ein und die cenit
betonrohr lüftungssystem der welt
wichtigen beitrag der jedoch schnell in
durchliefen dann eine reihe von
bemerkenswert die arbeit die hier
gesamtes leben hier verbracht
sind nur ein teil des ganzen damit eine
italienischen granate die über den 2200
atomzeitalter kam eine neue art von
hin dass der anschein täuscht
kanonen standen hier und ließen sich um
für die italiener ist die schlacht von
weise
erobert und zu einer japanischen kolonie
weltweit bekannt werden soll
dies ist die burg pitten sie
ihm aus erstrecken sich lange rohre wie
und die österreicher lagen her es war
antriebsmotor für die amerikanische
pulsierte das leben aber das gebäude hat
mitte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts ist
passiert etwas und es wurde unterrichtet
als alten römer bezeichnet ganz von der
zu piloten auszubilden im krieg gegen
innerhalb kürzester zeit verloren etwa
vor rund 100 jahren steht dieser ort an
geschäfte alles steht leer und ist
man überwältigt von seiner größe und
die ursprünge der burg reichen in das
erfordert einen umfangreichen
den teilungen polens plötzlich frieden
veredelungs prozessen so dass die
chinesen das sagen sie gründen die
von diesem fenster aus konnte man den
der gesamte bau ist voller seltsamer
glanz zurück
die verantwortlichen suchen einen
auszuführen die crews die engine und
zeit über das tal zu machen in den
homosexuell kabul ich habe es das
kabarett auf deutsch die front verlief
getrennte schulen für japanische kinder
jagdgeschwader mit seinen schwarzen
wir sind jetzt im kerker der burg hier
deshalb ein freies land weil die
vergessenheit gerät
erfindungsreichtum
dass sie im kalten krieg noch eine
maschine in der luft bleibt braucht es
airforce base spielte eine
dieses mal von china im ländlichen
tode
tentakel über die flügel
in dem man es sich gut gehen lässt er
rund 60 grad drehen
wie eine alte burg oder ein palast der
luftkrieg auf die not war eine wichtige
hier haben die bergleute gearbeitet aber
altburg bitte sie erneut ein schwerer
hatten eine mächtige marine sie
der boden ist von einer reihe steinerner
schönheit aber irgendetwas schlimmes
karfreitag der deutlichsten niederlagen
luftfahrt wurde das ist eine gruselige
der beginn der schlacht von karfreitag
seine verlobte maria eska eine
ausbildungs apparat die anlage wird
1940 gibt es landesweit nur 140 afro
hier fand einer der sinnlosesten und
den ersten schwarzen militärpiloten kam
meter hohen berg hinweg abgeschossen
gemacht es war der beginn einer
metalle auf dem weg nach unten immer
der krieg zurückgekehrt erst nehmen
unternehmungsgeist und tatendrang
piloten ein weg war sich offen zu zeigen
einfachen überholten schule
damit brach für die burg an goldenes
schlüsselrolle im luftkrieg das us army
500 italienische soldaten ums leben die
ausbildungsqualität entscheidung so hoch
der spitze der technischen entwicklung
jede menge fachwissen und personal am
passenden ort um die luft macht amerikas
feind beobachten und in unter beschuss
und für jene die von hier kamen
taiwanesische gold und kupfer baubehörde
hinweise auf die ursprünge der anlage
siebzehnte jahrhundert zurück
überwuchert den mittelpunkt bilden drei
japaner schickten kriegsgefangene in die
haben genau hier ihren anfang die
hat auch militärische merkmale wie die
errichteten kolonien erbeuteten überall
wichtige rolle spielt die usa sahen sich
ging es richtig familiär zu viele leute
sich an den hang schmiegt oder
muss damit passiert sein es wirkt als
designelemente
kriegt man direkt eine gänsehaut es ist
reiner wurden
wurde
kettenreaktion mit furchtbaren folgen
in der italienischen militärgeschichte
ausbildungsstätte in einer zeit in der
heute gibt es hier nichts mehr und es
mauern durchzogen das ganze wirkt
ein geheimnisvoller palast in der
in der oberen etage lagen die
geister statt die häuser sind allesamt
boden etwa ingenieure
schlag
verlustreichsten schlachten in einem der
ich habe hier so vieles erlebt meine
wunderschöne 16-jährige hat ihn
eine bedeutende rolle zu sie flogen mehr
zeitalter an denn sie lag nun in einer
war
hitlers soldaten das gebiet ein dann die
nehmen
gleichzeitig ist der schauplatz
erhöhte lage den wassergraben und die
aufzubauen
so ging man mit allen granaten vor rund
mine die mittlerweile die größte
cordula als chef des italienischen
liefert die start und landebahn die
wir führten getrennte leben 1943 ist der
angesichts der erschöpften gold
riesige hangar ähnliche bauten sie geben
vielleicht ein überwachtes tibetisches
rohstoffe und wollten so zu wohlstand
general luigi cordula wird der
fehler leben kosten konnten bei den
kalt und feucht das achtzehnte
amerikanische piloten aber das soll sich
b17 bomber zb hatte einen flugingenieur
die österreichischen
er hat zwei völlig unterschiedliche
angeblich ständig betrogen daraufhin
katastrophalsten konflikte aller zeiten
vernagelt es gibt ein altes theater und
für die region und für viele junge
friedlichen gegend in der die wirtschaft
irgendwie seltsam weitläufig verteilte
gesellschaftlicher veränderung das os
königlichen räume es gab mehrere säle
haben gerne miteinander gearbeitet sie
kupfermine im japanischen kaiserreich
ukraine
ist gefährlich darum wurde er
sinkender gewinne um drohender
gerade als der palast jahrhunderte des
rassismus anders als beispielsweise in
abgelegen rundherum ist flaches land und
vorkommen liegt der fokus nun auf der
rote armee
als 15.000 einsätze über nordafrika und
kloster
vor hermann kontrollierte das gesamte
befestigten bastionen um angreifer
tausende mitglieder der us airforce
generalstabs war der typische offizier
umrankt von intrigen wo ihnen an einem
gelangen
verteidigungsanlagen reichen tief unter
es ist extrem wichtig dass die
erste piste in der gegend wurde anfang
litauen die osteuropäische adels
oberbefehl entzogen trotz des erfolgs im
kindheit meine ausbildung mein
voll aufblühen konnte
natürlich einen hinweis darauf was das
dort wo man diese großen fensterlosen
diese festungsartig sich besser
200 stück ging dort nieder
war es waren vorwiegend britische und
seiten einerseits wirkt er wie ein
den mittelpunkt bilden drei gigantische
angesichts der vorrückenden truppen
statt
soll er sie aus argwohn und eifersucht
neuen luftwaffen handelt es sich um
bald ändern schwarze wurden ihr zunächst
amerikaner
den kopiloten den gelben und den
schadensersatzforderungen kurz darauf
an bord der hier auf dem chip field
mochten ihre jobs und ihre aufgaben sie
stillgelegt nachdem die arbeiter das
abzuwehren
raffination und veredelung von kupfer
aber es wirkt weder luxuriöser rituell
krieges und politischer turbulenzen
der us-army herrschte hier während der
man kann gut starten und landen
die erde dort dienen befestigte höhlen
durchlaufen hier ihre ausbildung
für ein gelände war aber der rest der
facharbeiter in den diversen bereichen
europa sie hatten also einen
tal mit hilfe guter aussichtspunkte mann
der 25 kilometer hinter der front im
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts fertig
titel
tyrone zu kolonialisieren war einer der
verteidigen weil es leichter war
hangars zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
ermordet haben ihr leichnam wurde nie
fackelt der hausherr nicht lange er
arbeitsleben
von diesem wohlstand haben die taiwanese
bögen sieht wurden das gestein und das
becken verlieren die mittelmächte
überstanden hatte und wieder zu alter
amerikanische soldaten
großzügiger landsitz mit großen fenstern
republik erstreckt sich auf gut 700
den betrieb einstellen der japanische
dazu kommt die zentrale lage in den usa
interkontinentalraketen sie gehören zu
europäischen thronsaal sie alle
haben einen sinn in ihrer arbeit gesehen
ausgebildet wurde dasselbe galt für den
ausbildung gleichberechtigung mann brach
der flugzeugwartung geschult werden eine
ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
gezielten schüsse abzugeben
aus der luft sieht nun die lang
noch wie ein wohngebäude es sind kaum
gestellt
anlage lässt vermuten dass es dort um
als bunker
erz verladen
1993 werden die streitkräfte verkleinert
packt die letzten schätze zusammen und
gefunden
ersten expansionsschritte japans später
hauptquartier sitzt fast außer hörweite
das ging mit enormen lärm einher was bei
insgesamt schafften hier 1100 alliierte
konnte von hier aus heranrückenden
österreich ungarn und deutschland den
den größten die bis dahin gebaut wurden
und ballsälen
pracht zurückzukehren hat jemand bei
beeinflussten den dekoration stil
ninja go machine nur wenig
also die rassentrennung innerhalb des us
für mich war dass auf jeden fall eine
tausend quadratkilometern
selbst jetzt im ruhestand wohne ich noch
der legende nach konnte ihre seele nicht
befindet sich die region unter
mehr ging
gezogenen spitzen ecken der bastionen
umfassend ausgebildete wartungs crew ist
zu der zeit war das fliegen ein
funker an bord einer b17 am 10 field gab
um sich vor schwerem artillerie beschuss
andererseits hat er etwas militärisches
truppen sehr leicht ins visier nehmen
aufgrund der bastionen unteregg türme
türen oder fenster zu sehen
anderer paläste und boden in der gegend
auch die deckengestaltung diente
flieht nach brasilien zurück bleibt nur
krieg und österreich-ungarn bricht
österreichischer herrschaft
jeglicher artillerie
mit diesem geist und erbe der innovation
militärs ein stück weit auf aus der
lötarbeiten im dachstuhl einen brand
vielen zu kriegstraumata filter
sollten sie sogar die amerikaner in
sehr wichtige zeit in einer abgelegenen
zur ruhe kommen sie soll irgendwo hier
das a und o dies ist die keynote air
schließlich wird die anlage geschlossen
aufregendes neues abenteuer es ging
kriegsgefangene viele kommen auf
die festungs form entspricht der neue
zu schützen richteten sie viele kavernen
hier
das innere der an das legt nahe dass sie
war sie schwerer einzunehmen
es gab kunstvoll verlegte parkettböden
sie liegt am rande von österreich-ungarn
es gibt einen wassergraben und kanonen
ausschließlich der effizienz
1965 begann man mit der veredelung
damals wurde der größte teil des goldes
es auch funk kurse reparatur kurse und
pearl harbor angreifen auf taiwan folgt
auseinander
verursacht viele der schäden die man
die burg wurde von stanislav donets
guter ausbildung und beständigkeit
das kahle gebäude als die russen am ende
unten begraben sein marias geist wäre
sogenannten hüllen schiffen aus singapur
hinweise auf die funktion des baus
er war autoritär und altmodisch ein
marmorne fensterbänke und die wände
darum grenzen zu überwinden
ein
italienischen manier und dient dazu
die österreichisch-ungarische
mit mitte 80 kann er sich noch gut an
aber keine noch so massiven
labor betz gibt es rund 500 davon am 29
stellungen dieses gebäude hat im laufe
nicht nur als lagerhallen genutzt wurden
nach kriegsende erhielt italien das
an der grenze zum frisch geeinten
andere spezielle lehrgänge es gibt vier
abgebaut und für national
wartet ein naheliegender ort für das
es gab einen 65 meter hohen schornstein
heute am palast sie stammen von diesen
bei dem chemischen prozessen in einem
polski erbaut er war gross hätte man
und von den philippinen
könnte die umliegende infrastruktur
das tal war strategisch wichtig
hängen voller kostbarer teppiche
kanonen beschuss abzuwehren
strenger befehlshaber er führte die
wirtschaftspolitik brachte wohlstand in
verteidigungsanlagen können das blutbad
die geschäftigen zeiten der anlage
feierlichkeiten nach japan geschickt die
italien italien hatte es auf das gebiet
vor
liefern
ersehnte stück land aber es war es
don pratt hat für 22 jahre lang
titan raketenprogramm
hüttenwerk sind große mengen hitze und
die meisten mussten fast drei jahre lang
also ein enger berater des königs
die gegend und die festung wurde zu
verhindern dass sich schon bald im
truppen wie ein diktator
aber der stand sehr nahe an der anlage
von ihm gehen lange rohre wie tentakel
erinnern
noch lange nicht auf
als sie noch in betrieb waren müssen
wenn angreifer ist unbehelligt
energie im spiel um das erz und seine
die burg wurde zum vorzeigeobjekt mit
darunter liegenden teil zu tragen soll
sicher nicht wert dass dafür mehrere
direkt an der grenze in den südöstlichen
die arbeiten unter mindestens genauso
gearbeitet
als eines der ersten ziele nimmt cordula
ich habe an einem versuch mit sulfiden
er verlor enorm viele sollte hatten bei
allem getrotzt und die jahrhunderte
dadurch war die sulfat belastung extrem
die hinter dem drücken verschwinden sie
für ein militärisches bauwerk das
er war sehr mächtig und wollte einen
bestandteile zu zerlegen
durchqueren und auf die anhöhe gelangen
hundert tausend soldaten gefallen waren
alpen abgesehen obwohl es damals
diese großen hangars voller maschinen
denn die italiener wiederum betrachten
in die 1950 er jahren beschloss die
schlimm bedingungen wie bei der todes
bis zum ruhestand hiergeblieben viel hat
dem man den neuen wohlstand zur schau
und kupfer mitgearbeitet
vor hermann ins visier
überdauert hatte als wäre sie für die
hoch das war für die anwohner und
palast bauen der seine rolle in der
würden könnten sie ins landesinnere von
eisenbahn in burma die durch filme wie
verteidigt werden musste war das eine
sinnlosen angriffen und kritisierte dann
und die italienische wirtschaft
das gebiet auf der anderen seite der
spaces das geschieht mit hilfe einer
österreich-ungarn unterstand
stellte aber hinter den kulissen
fluggeräte ausrüstung und menschen
regierung alle sieben raketenprogramme
nicht gefehlt
praktisch zerstört wurde
republik polen litauen widerspiegelte
grenze als ihren rechtmäßigen besitz
in erwartung eines angriffs verstärken
kluge idee von connys polski denn im
die brücke am kwai berüchtigt wurde
ton liter und vordringen in den ersten
ewigkeit gebaut
war die dichte der sulfide zu hoch
mich jetzt hier umzusehen tut weh das
seine kommandeure deren einheiten von
arbeiter giftig
reihe chemische reaktionen bei denen man
nachstellung zu verlegen und hier die
wurde absurderweise bei einem einfachen
gewesen sein durch ihre größe und lehre
1900 als sich bereits ein krieg
laufe der jahre sollte der palast
die österreicher ihre verteidigung im
als der erste weltkrieg ausbrach hätte
konnten wir kein gold und kupfer
die gewünschten metalle trend und aus
österreichischer artillerie und mg feuer
ausbildung durchzuführen
heute zeugen nur noch die verstreuten
wird mir schwer es war so eine schöne
der historiker ivan dodig hat die
abzeichnet stellen die österreicher das
tatsächlich in den mittelpunkt einige
haus brand zerstört doch es gibt bereits
viele kommen dabei ums leben heute
darunterliegenden tal den sogenannten
die emissionen auf sicherem wege
extrahieren
es war also die haupt ausbildungsstätte
oxidiert
anlage sie war entscheidend für die
dezimiert wurden er machte immer so
italien auf seiten des deutschen reichs
ruinen von den erbitterten schlachten
schlachten und angriffe geraten die
vor hermann fertig
geschichte des gebäudes erforscht hinter
badge beckmann es schlängelt sich eine
und österreich-ungarns kämpfen sollen
abzulassen stellt die ingenieure vor
für den raketenabschuss und die wartung
erinnert ein kriegsgefangenen denkmal an
also mussten wir das ganze zermahlen um
aber das kostbare gold bleibt nicht etwa
weiter obwohl er kaum boden gutmachen
sicherheit der vereinigten staaten
mittlerweile gehört das gebiet zu
aber es blieb zunächst neutral letztlich
vor hermann diente dazu um schwere
einer herausforderung letztlich bauten
sie das jahrzehnte später errichtet wird
konnte
slowenien und heißt dort sco parits
zu der zeit als die anlage in betrieb
hier fort als die anlage in den 1930 er
die edelmetalle zu gewinnen dies ist das
waren es die alten mächte die italien
waffen zu stationieren um das tal und
geht sieht sich das us-militär einem
der angriff der italiener auf vor
die größte aussicht auf erfolg
jahren errichtet wird gehört die insel
den pass zu kontrollieren an jedem
problem gegenüber die luftfahrt machte
versprachen die atommächte sagen italien
hermann läutet den beginn von kordon
taiwan nicht zu china
wichtigen pass oder tal fanden sich
nass unglückseligen feldzug entlang der
zwar ihre ersten großen fortschritte in
damals arbeiteten schanz vater unter
militärische stellungen die nur sehr
den usa aber das land machte sich diese
berüchtigten sofort ein die südlich vom
schwer einzunehmen waren
technik nur sehr langsam zu nutze
brutalen bedingungen für andere
vor hermann verläuft hier sollen sich
herrscher
die gebrüder wright haben zwar den
einige der blutigsten schlachten des
historiker und fremdenführer wladimir
und die schriftzüge in cannes sie
grundstein gelegt aber 1917 waren die
ersten weltkriegs abspielen
lipowicz kennt das verteidigungssystem
verraten wer sie waren
amerikaner in sachen luftfahrttechnik
die frontlinie war nur rund 100
genau entlang der grenze zwischen
japaner
abgehängt dieser ort wurde geschaffen um
kilometer lang und entlang dieser 100
als die japaner taiwan ende des
das zu ändern der us-kongress hat 1917
kilometer kamen im laufe des krieges
neunzehnten jahrhunderts eroberten
300.000 italiener und 200.000
wollten sie es zu einem teil ihres ewig
währenden groß reiches machen also
österreicher ums leben damit war dies
bauten sie nicht nur vertreten und
einer der blutigsten kriegsschauplätze
schmelzhütten sondern auch schweine
diesen fans schreien etwa haben sie den
überhaupt schließlich endete dort alles
berg gott gewidmet
anfangs strebt japan eine friedliche und
stabile kolonialherrschaft an aber dann
wird das gold wichtiger als die
gesundheit der arbeiter sowie im fall
von schenkenschanz vater
mein vater war als bergarbeiter
beschäftigt und trug das erz in der mine
ab ich war vier jahre alt als er starb
[Musik]